ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد الى نقاش ملفنا
الثاني سجلت وزاره الري العراقيه من جديد
تراجعا في منسوب مياه نهري دجله والفرات
جنوب البلاد مما فرض على السلطات العراقيه
اتخاذ اجراءات مختلفه لمعالجه الازمه ولكن
قبل الدخول في الحلول اتهمها بيان لوزاره
الري العراقيه اتهم الجاره تركيا بالتسبب
بقله المياه الوارده الى سد الموصل على
دجله وسط حديثه على الفرات مشيره الى ان
ذلك ادى الى انخفاض حاد في المخزون المائي
بالبلاد الوزاره قالت ان هناك عاملا ذاتيا
ايضا ادى الى وقوع ازمه المياه وربطته
بعدم التزام المزارعين بخطط الوزاره والذي
ادى وفق المسؤولين الى زياده الاستهلاكات
الماليه من حوض نهر الغراف ونهر الفرات ما
القى بظلاله على قله المياه الوارده ووفق
تقارير اعلاميه فان العراق غالبا ما يواجه
ازمه نقص المياه عبر حفظها في السدود شمال
البلاد ما يثير غضب المحافظات الجنوبيه في
العراق
تتهم بغداد انقره بالتسبب بشح المياه في
مناسيب نهري دجله والفرات
ما ادى الى نقص كبير في المخزون المائي
تزامنا مع قله الامطار
يعاني العراق من شح المياه بسبب سد اليسا
التركي المشيد عند منبع نهر دجله وهو ثاني
اكبر سد في تركيا بعد سد اتاتورك على نهر
الفرات
نعم شكرا جزيلا لكم تحيه لكم مشاهديكم
الكرام للضيف الكريم بطبيعه الحال هي
مشكله المياه مع تركيا ليست بالجديده
وانما يعني ربما بدات منذ عام 1946 ثم تلت
هذه الازمات الى سبعينات القرن الماضي
وثمانيناته وانتهاء الى عام 2003 وما
بعدها تركيا اقامت
مئات السدود باكثر من 720 سدا على على
مجرى دجله والفرات والفرات بالتحديد وقامت
سدود كبيره منها سد اتاتورك
وسدود اخرى وسد اليسا وبالتالي كل هذه
السدود اثرت على كميه المياه الوارده
للعراق وجمله من مفاوضات والاتفاقات ربما
كان منها بتقصير من الحكومات العراقيه
المتعاقبه يعني من عام
2003 الى اليوم ولكن حضرتك تركيا تعتبر
بان دجله والفرات لا يمكن معامله او لا
يمكن التعامل مع بلد ثاني فيما يخصهما لان
تركيا تعتبر بان هذين النهرين يتبعان
الجهه التركيه فلا يمكن ان تناقش هذا
الموضوع تحت طائله المواثق الدوليه تقول
بان هذين النهرين
يعني المنبع هو تركيا المجرى هو تركيا
فانا ليلحق في التحكم فيها
لا يا سيده الفاضله ليس هكذا المياه لا
يحق لاحد ان يتحكم بها باعتبار هي موارد
طبيعيه وبالتالي هنالك اتفاقات دوليه وما
تشير اليها الدول المتشاطئه وبالتالي
الحصص هي لا يمكن ان تكون حكرا يعني من
دوله على حساب اخرى والمياه في العراق
تشكل بحدود يعني موارد المياه في العراق
تشكل بحدود 70% من تركيا وهذه النسبه
انخفضت الى اكثر من 50% بسبب هذه السدود
حضرتك موجود
بان الحروب القادمه ستكون حروب مياه ولكنك
تقول بانه لا يجب ان تحتكر اي دوله
هكذا موضوع يعني يخص دول الجوار دكتور
باكير هل تحتكر تركيا المياه هل تحتكر هذا
الموضوع
وتصعب
الملف على داخل العراقي
دكتور بكير هل تسمعني
مساء الخير تحياتي لك ولضيفك الكريم للاسف
الشديد العراق منذ فتره طويله تدعي بين
الحين والاخر بان مشكله المياه هي مشكله
تنبع من من تركيا ولكن للاسف الشديد منذ
عشر سنوات تركيا قدمت قروض وطالبت بتغيير
يعني
البنيه التحتيه لنهر الفرات ودجله وايضا
خاصه الخرسانات التي تنقل المياه
لن او لا اقول لن توافق العراق اخذت
المبالغ المخصصه لها من تركيا ولكن الى
الان لم تفعل شيئا علما بان تركيا قالت
نحن على استعداد لمساعده العراق قبل سنتين
مستشار مستشار
اردوغانو ذهب الى العراق وعرض عليهم ان
تكون اتفاقيات جديده لانه هو كما هو معروف
هناك مشاكل في المياه بين الحين والاخر
بين تركيا والعراق منذ فتره طويله لابد ان
تحل ولكن للاسف الى الان لن ياتي لا وفد
ولا اي
زائر من العراق لا في تركيا ولا في العراق
لكي يجتمعوا ويحل هذه المشكله مع بعضهم
البعض ولكن عندما تقول اخر ولكن حضرتك لما
تتحمل اموال تلقتها العراق من تركيا ولم
تستجب او لم على الاقل تنفذ ما اتفق عليه
فنحن امام شيء اخر نحن امام ملف فساد كبير
فدخل العراقي لا اعلم ساعود لك بخصوص هذه
النقطه ولكن خليني اسمع تعليق الاستاذ
واثق فيها
لا نعم هي تركيا لم تعطل اموالا وانما هو
العراق يعني في اكثر من مره جرب يعني او
او حاول التحاور مع تركيا وفي اخره ناتي
من الاخير السيد محمد شاعر السوداني رئيس
الوزراء الحالي اتصل بالرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان
يفترض ان يشكل لجنه مشتركه بين البلدين
برئاسه نائب رئيس البرلمان
المندلاوي لكن لحد الان لم تفعل معظم
الاتفاقات واوراق العمل والمذكرات تفاهم
بين الدولتين على كميه المياه لم تلتزم
تركيا
بحجم الاطلاقات المائيه نحن في العراق
ربما هنالك يعني يقول اسمح لي فقط
للمقاطعه ضيفي يقول بانه تركيا الموضوع لا
يخص الالتزام من عدمه يقول بان تركيا رتبت
الامور على اساس تغيير بنيه تحتيه لهذه
الانهار وقدمت اموال حضرتك تنكر او على
الاقل تنفيذ ذلك يقول بان تركيا مكنت
الجانب العراقي بما يخوله القيام بتغييرات
على مستوى هذه البنيه التحتيه ما لم تفعله
العراق
العراق لديه خزانات وبحيرات كبيره يعني
يمكن ان تخزن المياه لكن انا قلت نعم في
العراق ربما طريقه السقي والراي
والتجاوزات على على المياه وتوزيع المياه
بصوره غير صحيحه نعم هكذا والمياه معظمها
تذهب الى الى شط العرب لكن بالنتيجه يعني
كميه الاطلاقات الان انخفضت الى اقل من
خمسين بالمئه وبالتالي اثرت بشكل كبير
واليوم على انهر في في مدن الجنوب يعني
نسبه الاهوار يعني انخفضت المياه فيها
اكثر من 60% وهنالك دجله والفرات في
الناصريه وميسان جفت يعني تماما وبالتالي
هذه تاتي من دول المنبع ليس بسبب يعني عدم
خزن المياه المناطق الجنوبيه اصبحت مناطق
منكوبه تتحدث عن ناصريه وهناك مناطق اخرى
في محيطها يصفها البعض حتى بان سكانها
يعني
هجروا هذه المناطق لانهم يعيشون على تربيه
الماشيه ليس هناك عشب ليست هناك مياه
فاضطروا الى مغادره هذه المناطق وهذا موجع
في الواقع ولكن استاذ بكير البعض كذلك
يلقي باللوم على تركيا ويقول بان تركيا
تحاول طرح معادله جديده نفط وغاز
السليمانيه مقابل
المياه مقابل مياه دجله والفرات هل هذا
ممكن لا يا عزيزتي لا للاسف الشديد
يعني المسؤولين العراقيين يتهربون من بعض
الحقائق اولا السدود التي بنيت على الفرات
والدجله خلال السنوات عشر سنوات الماضيه
كلها
لن تكون يعني كانت من اجل التوليد الطاقه
الكهربائيه وليست سدود
للمزارع اولا نقطه هامه جدا لتوليد الطاقه
بمعنى اخر تركيا لا تحتاج هذه المياه
لاسباب اخرى فقط لتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه
وهذه لابد ان تترك المياه ولكن نقطه هذه
المياه لابد ان تمر من سوريا ومن ثم من
سوريا من داخل الاراضي السوريه الى العراق
ومن ثم الى شط العرب وهذه تحتاج الى تجديد
وتحديث البنيه التحتيه ولكن العراق للاسف
الشديد لن تقدم شيئا فقط تطلب
زياده المياه كل مره نقول لهم هنا في جفاف
في مشاكل مناخ لابد ان تكون اتفاقيات
جديده ولكن تصر على شيء واحد بانهم يريدون
كميات المياه ان تضخ كثيره وهذه غير ممكن
للان ولا في المستقبل لذلك على الحكومه
العراقيه ان تعرف جيدا في مثل يقول ضربني
وبكى سبقني واشتكى يعني هؤلاء لن يفعلوا
شيء ولكن يشتكون فاذا كانت هذه الشقه لهم
الحق فيها فعليه ان يقدموا بهذه الشكوى
الى الامم المتحده والى المحاكم الدوليه
بان تركيا تقصر لا تفعل بناء على
الاتفاقيات التي وقعت بينهما ولكن للاسف
الشديد لا يستطيعون الذهاب الى هذه
المحاكم لان الفساد واضح
لانك
واضحه هم ربما كذلك سرقوا كل شيء وبالاخير
يقول تركيا نعم نعم ولكن قد يقول البعض
لان التدوير الناس لا تستطيع قد تاخذ
كبيره في تركيا ولكن عليهم ان يعرفوا جيدا
بان هذه البنيه الموجوده تحتيه اذا لن
تتحدث وتتطور غير ممكن ان وضحت هذه النقطه
ولكننا تقول بان الجانب العراقي لن يتوجه
الى الامم المتحده لان هناك ملفات فساد قد
يقول لك البعض الاخر بانه ليست فقط ملفات
الفساد قد تعيق هذا الذهاب ولكن تدويل
القضيه ياخذ وقت طويل وموضوع المياه موضوع
اني موضوع اساسي موضوع حيوي فلا يمكن
تاجيله خاصه وان مسار المفاوضات
الدبلوماسيه لها تاريخ فيمكن استكمال بطرح
بعض النقاط ولكن سانهي معك استاذ واثق منذ
قليل لما سالت على معادله النفط مقابل
المياه اشاراتك كانت تؤكد بان هذا هو
المغزى الحديث
هل هذا دقيق
نعم يعني هي تركيا تريد الاستثمار يعني في
مجال الغاز بالذات في منطقه السليمانيه
وتريد ايضا يعني ان يكون يعني من شمال
العراق او ممرات النفط تمر من خلال تركيا
بالاضافه الى استغلالها يعني الازمه
المياه وتحويل المياه الى مزارع وتروح
حيوانيه من اجل تصديرها الى العراق
باعتبار العراق ان اليوم حاله الجفاف
تدعوه الى ان يستورد يعني
المواد الزراعيه ويستورد ايضا الثروه
الحيوانيه ومنتجاتها من تركيا وبالتالي هي
تستثمر الازمه العراق لم يتعامل يعني مع
تركيا بالمثل بل العراق يعني كانت يتعامل
مع تركيا بحسن الجوار عندما حدثت يعني
الان عندما حدثت ازمه في تركيا اول من هبه
الحكومه العراقيه الشيء الثاني لا يريد
القضيه ان تدول او ربما تصبح يعني نقطه
خلاف بين البلدين وانما تركيا تحاول ان
تستخدم هذه الورقه كورقه سياسيه واقتصاديه
وايضا امنيه في نفس الوقت باعتبار هي مره
للضغط على الحكومه العراقيه من اجل ملاحقه
حزب العمال كردستاني البككه ومره اخرى من
اجل يعني ان تنقذ اقتصادها المتراجع ومره
اخرى من اجل فرض سياسات معينه وبالتالي هي
حرب من نوع اخر هي حرب المياه هو هذه اثرت
بشكل كبير على العراق وكما اشرت جنابك الى
يعني مساله يعني الحياه التي تاثرت يعني
هجره كثير من المناطق الجنوبيه واثرت في
الثروه الحيوانيه والزراعه كما تعرفون ان
حتى مناطق الاهواء في جنوب العراق اليوم
ضيفي منذ قليل هو تحدث كذلك عن ملفات فساد
في الدخل العراقي يقول بان الحكومات
المتعاقبه لم تدرك
او لم تدر هذا الملف بطريقه يؤهلها الى
الانتفاع من كل هذه السنوات
يستفاد من المواطن نحن تحدثنا عن
المواطنين تضررنا نتحدث عن الحكومات
الحكومات لا تتاجر بالمياه او لا يستفيد
يعني اساسها بشكل مباشر وانما تؤثر بشكل
عام على حياه المواطنين اليوم انا قلت
يعني عشرات المدن في العراق هي هاجرت
واصبحت مهجوره وربما يعني تضررت كثير من
الثروه الحيوانيه والزراعيها لا مواطنين
لا علاقه لهم بالسياسه وليسوا رجال سياسه
ولن يستفيد احدا من الفساد وبالتالي هذه
القضيه هذه القضيه لا تتعلق بمساله فساد
او مساله
استحواذ حكم الحكومه لا علاقه لها هي
تتعلق بطبيعه يعني ربما حتى ولدت مشاكل
يعني في داخل المناطق العراقيه في مساله
التجاوزات يعني يعني ربما ولدت نوع من
الخلافات داخل في المجتمع العراقي بين مدن
واخرى فلا مساله الحصص
يتحدث عن اكبر من خلافات يتحدث عن حتى
امكانيه ان تكون هناك مناوشات عشائريه بين
منطقه واخرى وهذا ما لا يعود
حدثت حدثت مناوشات عشائريه نعم
موضوع يبقى دائما للمتابعه ساكتفي بهذا
القدر على ان نعود لنستكمله ربما مع فتح
افق جديد
لمسار دبلوماسي لمحاوله ايجاد حلول اود
شكركم من اسطنبول للدكتور بكير تجان مدير
معهد اسطنبول للفكر ومن بغداد الباحث
السياسي وثقل شكرا لكما